when I see George RR Martin's White
Walkers depicted in the game of Thrones
series I have to tell you I couldn't
help but think they have a lot in common
with the drug or especially in
appearance
you obviously know of the drug or
through your numerous studies of ancient
Nordic culture or from playing hours of
Skyrim but in the far off chance you
haven't done either of those things let
me explain
drag ores are ancient Nordic Undead
humanoid monsters who rise from their
graves to kill wreak havoc and generally
disrupt the living so what can drag or
say about Vikings ancient burial
ceremonies and cooking dinner naked to
me what's so fascinating about these
creatures is how they can teach us so
much about the lives of the people who
lived thousands of years ago and that
some of the strongest Nordic warriors
were actually women I'm dr. Emily szarka
and this is monstrum
we know of the drug war from the sagas
of the Icelanders stories that relate
the early history and people of Iceland
from the late 9th century to the end of
the Viking era yes I am using air quotes
because the term Viking is not a
national or ethnic identity but a
profession
the act of raiding two kinds of undead
creatures emerged me sokka's the who
heed boy
we Bowie who get boy the hog a boo-boo I
don't know nothing who pretty much just
hung out in their burial sites leaving
people alone and the drug or who left
their graves to harm the living there
were very specific reasons by a newly
buried person would transform into
either one of these monsters common and
seemingly random reasons for a person to
become either type of undead monster
included practicing black magic being
executed as capital punishment dying in
accidental death try avoiding that one
or being buried outside of a church yard
once reanimated the drug or are said to
have been more active at night and in
the winter sometimes the appearance of
the drug orc was foretold by a mist or
temporary darkness again this feels
familiar
draaga are scary they'll kill you and
your livestock and engage in one of
their favorite pastimes riding roots
which from what I can gather pretty much
just meant stomping around on the roof
at night making noise so people can't
get any sleep which is more annoying
than terrifying but let's not forget
they'll also kill it
these monsters are often described as
possessing the northern strength like
the ancient Egyptians the old Nordic
people believe that you've literally
take what you were buried with to the
next plane of existence a huge piece of
evidence for this is the grave goods
that have been found at burial sites the
Nordic people also practice the corpse
store custom it was believed that the
dead could only return the way they left
the home so to keep the dead from
returning a wall or portion of a house
would be removed to carry the corpse
outside for burial
then the corpse door would be quickly
repaired this prevented the undead from
making any surprise visits all of these
cultural practices are reflected in the
sagas of the Icelanders through
encounters with Drago's many of these
monsters are a test for the stories hero
or heroine and often reflect the power
struggles between different kinship
groups or even within families perhaps
the most famous stronger story pops up
in grete saga when the hero Greta
defeats glamour a particularly
aggressive draugar in an epic wrestling
match Greta ends up sending glamour to
her permanent death by decapitating him
than burning his body and varying the
ashes here we find the only way to
successfully retail a drug war it's a
method that pops up in other sagas the
only way to immobilize the drug war is
to chop off the head burn the body and
scatter the ashes
this is actually one thing Skyrim got
right fire is an excellent weapon
against raw gore and White Walkers just
saying and the saga of the people of
Avery a Wallis built around a new burial
site to prevent a particularly dangerous
Drago from returning the wall was so
high the quote no one could see over it
except a bird in flight they literally
build a wall to try and stop the undead
how is this not an influence for Game of
Thrones but not all DRA Gore or violent
monsters one such example is Thor goona
she was so offended by the poor
hospitality offered to the men carrying
her corpse to her burial that she comes
back from the dead to make dinner for
them naked before being buried restfully
this time at a church the best part they
all eat the food would you eat zombie
food now we get to talk about my
favorite Icelandic story the saga of
King high freq the wise it's amazing in
so many ways but mostly because of the
shield maiden hair war who absolutely
should become your new favorite literary
heroine hair war who is as strong as a
man and trained in BO shield and sword
decides she wants to retrieve a dwarves
magical sword buried with her father and
uncles she puts on male clothes changes
her name to hair vard and joins up with
some Vikings and because she's a total
boss she even becomes captain of her own
band of Vikings hair for travels many
miles to reach her ancestral burial
mound her father tries to scare her away
but hair war is having none of that and
she manages to convince him to give her
the sword after a little more living it
up as a Viking she grows tired of it all
hangs up her gear and retires eventually
getting married and having children a
huge part of ancient Nordic and
particularly Icelandic sagas is the
inclusion of undead monsters threatening
the lives and sanity of living the
ancient Nordic peoples proximity to
death and their religious beliefs made
burial a sacred but often imperfect
practice and their kinship with
ancestors was so important it could
literally last beyond the grave to me
what's so fascinating about these
creatures is how they can teach us so
much about the lives of the people who
lived
thousands of years ago thanks for
watching monstrum do you have a favorite
monster myth you'd like to see on the
show let me know in the comments and
don't forget to subscribe
[Music]